foreign
well as you know John we scoured the
internet for the latest and greatest
videos and there's one that's talking
about the student loan forgiveness
should you pay off your student loans
right now and so I wanted to play it for
you and get your take you good with that
the last few times you sprung a tick
tock video on me Let's Do It Go For It
Roll the beautiful Bean footage everyone
I saw this headline today in the news
and I just wanted to kind of talk about
it because it is interesting there's
potential to have some sort of student
loan forgiveness on federal student loan
debt here being announced in the next
couple weeks so you know I myself have
actually paid a little over five
thousand dollars this year with interest
rates staying at zero percent it's
allowed me to make a significant dent in
my balance but you know I might not want
to keep paying that as we get closer to
August 31st especially if there's going
to be some sort of forgiveness
I might switch my strategy instead of
going right to my student loan balance
I'm going to put that in savings and
then maybe wait and see what what this
announcement is going to be like so stay
tuned we'll keep you up to date but
would love to hear your thoughts in my
comments and maybe what some of your
strategies are right now thanks
oh I'll give you some thoughts and
strategies John well hold on
I know did you just hear the there's the
Paradox there I there is but can we just
call out most people on Tick Tock that
you've shown me in the past because I
don't even know how to I would not even
know how to log it I don't give you
access John it's too dangerous you can't
handle it yet that guy seems like a nice
guy yeah I'm not mad at the guy he said
look a nice guy he was commentating on
music it's very calming music I really
enjoyed that actually yeah I feel a
little bit more at peace so the article
behind them that you can't see if you're
listening uh was from Bloomberg said
don't bother paying off student loan
debt right now advisors say who are
these advisors we don't know why do they
want to keep people in debt I have no
idea but what's funny is this gentleman
saying hey I've been paying off my
student loan debt I'm really feeling the
progress as I make a dent in the
principal while the interest is paused
but I might hold off now to see what
happens here and I think he represents a
lot of Americans out there going well
I'm not going to buy them off because
what if what if what if
so George you know I've just we've
talked about this a lot just privately
um
my my two thoughts are this
um one I am getting this is just reality
and be disingenuous to not say this I do
have friends of mine across the country
who are in various Fields where they've
um most of my friends are nerds no shock
that have their doctorates and or have
their law degree that have gotten notice
over the last six months that hey we've
your loans have been forgiven like and
they're gone
um it's a very specific type of loan in
a very specific specific type of program
but I hadn't heard that before so that's
actually happened
the other side of it is it's not
wholesale right and this idea that this
is just going to happen and I think you
and I today were talking I think this is
going to get punted and punted and
punted and they're going to have some
sort of small low level we'll take away
five thousand or ten thousand or
something like that with some sort of
right around midterms and try to swing
something back
here's the bigger deal for me
um I grew up didn't have a lot growing
up
my wife grew up she didn't have a lot
with great parents who worked their
butts off for their communities we just
have a lot of money and we signed up
went to college because that's what
you're supposed to do and then we kept
then my wife went to got her Master's
Degree I got my Master's Degree she got
her doctorate I got my doctorate and we
look up and we had 106 figures in in
student loan debt right
I I knew we had to pay it back but I
didn't I didn't get it and I didn't know
what 30 years at 900 a month meant you
know what I mean I was 18 and then I was
21.
but
I always had this nagging sense that I
signed my name on a piece of paper and I
told somebody if you help me get through
college I'll pay you back and they did
whoever they happened to be
and I felt a Integrity obligation two
poor kids
who are lower middle class kids who got
into it but we still signed our name to
this thing and it's kind of like
um like in the nutrition world right now
all of the conversations are about
um like calories are returning this idea
that a lot of a lot of the problems you
see Downstream is because of some fancy
diet but you got to get back to thinking
about calories that's just what the
science is telling us
and that's very very true
and if I just eat Twinkies every single
day because they're 50 cents
that will cost me at some point in my
life right even if I look at the calorie
density unless it's going to cost me and
so we can all clap and cheer that the
loans get taken away and we just roll
another 1.7 trillion dollars on we will
pay for this and it will be really rough
when we do and so for me in my house it
was about looking in the mirror saying
we did this we said we're going to pay
it off do we know we're going to no are
we in a mess yes was it an awful couple
years getting that stuff paid off
absolutely
but I walk a little bit taller right and
I'm not sitting there just waiting and
waiting and waiting and waiting and so I
love the first part of that video where
he says man we've had no interest this
if there's ever a moment to burn through
your loans right now pay them off you
don't they're not making any money on it
right yeah that's my that's my take on
it that's a good take and I I as well
walk the stage with a 36 000 in student
loan debt not as much as you
um and I just thought I don't remember
signing up for this like I remember the
conversation with my dad was like this
hey Dad how are we gonna pay for college
and he's like ah we we got it taken care
of what I didn't know was that meant
we're gonna sign up for student loans
Parent Plus Loans to make sure it's
taken care of and when you're 18 you
don't know you're just go to school
going this is fun yeah the college
experience I'm not thinking about money
I don't have a job the number of
t-shirts and dinners I put on student
loans it just is it's it's
mind-numbing yeah it's maddening So to
that point pay off your student loans
stop waiting for someone to fix your
life because if that's how you look at
student loans that's probably how you
look at other areas of life right well
this is my problem I didn't sign up for
this and at what point do we go I signed
up for all these credit cards and now
I'm in debt they should forgive them
right at what point do we draw the line
and I'll even say this um just because I
was so intimately involved in this
industry
um there are people that were preyed
upon whole groups of people that were
literally targeted they don't know
enough they'll sign up for this we can
get them on the hook and so at its core
I'm not even opposed to a
like relieving of some of this debt and
we're seeing some of that happen now
yeah I've I've got no moral issue
because people were trapped not just
even my case right people were preyed
upon I was just made it in ill-informed
decision
but you can't pay you can't forgive the
loans because all these students are
gonna if we all got our loans forgiven
in May
I gotta sign up for the summer term in
June what are we gonna do and so until
you fix the front end of this deal until
you sit down and say all right how are
we going to fix the college mess yeah
and the cost of college and the value of
college until we have that conversation
dude this is it's like drilling a hole
in your bathtub without turning I mean
it's like turn the water off yeah throw
the water off first oh man yeah we talk
about this in borrowed future or
documentary that you're in good stuff
there John appreciate it thanks for
let me watch yet another ticket
enlightening you you're welcome